hello and welcome to this video playing
valise cotta ba-ba-boom poder Huma
what on earth
Oh I wanted to go knock deaf six of
course
okay well f6 is not what I wanted but
also not not completely terrible
probably okay what is going on yeah f3
I'm just taking some center control and
you don't okay that looks funny
I can't so let's go c5 or is he is he
coming is he playing some sort of
deforming
[Music]
yes there are some ways here to Trajan
to punish White's player I'm not certain
about them wow really
and now I'm tempted to shut everything
down there like with b5 and E for trying
to kill this Bishop on e3 but okay it's
not a very time-sensitive issue can
definitely first connect troops and only
then decide to do something more more
drastic so we form
yeah that's the moment for a five the
moment when he cannot take now a three
is unprotected so B takes a five is not
possible
okay we'll see what he is playing next
time
one one thing that I can do here has a
very simple way of doing such a form
just a 4 a 4 B 5 would be eternally
better for me he's got this extremely
passive Queen side and I can open up on
the kingside it's just there's no way
he's preventing this he's got everything
on the Queen side so I can act quickly
on the other side of the border okay
Jade next this is very simple to to
organize here because you don't have to
very much about counter play
yeah but is going to do him he basically
has to take a thought okay I didn't
think putting allowing the rookie on the
second is a good idea okay
Nyjah form
yeah okay I don't want to retreat here
and I really don't want to
the position is too good to retreat
really and then now yeah they're just
too many threats 94 and 95 this is
really quite quite funny okay I can also
take on a form let's go here that's just
a funny funny move the a3 bishop it's
just impossible to to hold okay
I mean a3 is not even the best move I
guess like if we if we look at this this
is even better I think when I take
therefore is coming a3 it would have
just won the piece but what kind of
position is that
and now I will take between us
okay so check on these three but not
sure this night oh the most nights were
made for jumping
yeah a bit of an odd game but let's
let's have a look yeah Bishop Bishop III
is not really recommended okay you can I
think relatively best is probably a 3m
which is going to be slightly better for
black but no it's not like an immediate
loss or anything yeah okay the engine
even wanted to go 85 but just to take
the center is good
we have 6s for just a mouse lip I wanted
to play Knight f6 of course but yeah I
mean that it's not bad you just well
white is doing something weird we just
develop and control in the center b6
just controlled c5 and prepares to push
this pawn to c5 and here's c5 also was a
good idea with f5 wind just take the
center it gets funny that like stock
Fischer's knight c6 is already - 4 with
equal material but ok White's position
is quite weird I decided to play it in a
simple way here this a 4 B 5 this is
just never going to hold then you have
too many weirdly placed pieces as wide k
h6 g5 must be right and the ng 5 GG 5
will appear I mean it's not yet here on
the on the comms list but it will appear
maybe not
I thought g5 is a powerful idea anyway
yeah ok the computer at least is also on
- 3 I thought it was a good idea to just
open open the position as quickly as
possible I have a multitude of options
yeah here I don't really want to retreat
that's that's no good
you can easily give up the exchange that
the position is just too bad you three
years is basically gone yeah okay he
went through cage one take him and
you're just picking up everything step
by step and he already couldn't avoid
the the Big Fork now that that opening
was a bit a bit too much creativity yeah
thanks a lot for watching